العربيه بان اسرائيل قامت بتفعيل منظومه
القبه الحديديه بعد رصد طائره مسيره فوق
قطاع غزه واضاف انه لم يتم تفعيل صفاره
الانذار في اسرائيل مع مشاهده مقاتلات
اسرائيليه تحلق فوق قطع غزه
من القسم المشاهدين انضم الينا لانا قرصي
مراسله العربي اهلا بك لانا ما هي
المعلومات التي توفرت لديك حول ما يحدث
حول قطاع غزه
اهلا احمد نعم نحن نتحدث عن مسيره بدون
طيار اطلقت من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه واطلقت الى السماء في الاجواء في
قطاع غزه وايضا يعني تدعي اسرائيل انها
اقتربت ايضا من المستوطنات الموجوده على
يعني المحاديه لقطاع غزه وقامت فعليا
بتفعيل القبه الحديديه ما ادى ايضا الى
اسقاط هذه المسيره والان القوات
الاسرائيليه تجري يعني تحقيقات بشان هذه
المسيره ولكن دعنا ايضا نشير ان هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي تقوم القوات
الاسرائيليه باسقاط مسيره تم اطلاقها من
قطاع غزه الان ايضا نحن نتحدث عن عدم
تفعيل ايضا انذار ما ادى ايضا الى افزاع
وتخويف المستوطنين الموجودين في قطاع غزه
ولكن ايضا هذه ليست المره الاولى التي
تقوم فيها بتفعيل القبه الحديديه دون
اطلاق انذار طيب لان نتابع صورنا في
الجانب الاخر من الشاشه هي صور متداوله
تحليق طائرات اسرائيليه حول او في محيط
قطاع غزه اذا هذا ياتي في عقاب التوتر
الذي نجم عن تحاليق ايضا طائره مسيره
انطلقت من قطاع غزه وارصدت فوق في محيط
هذا القطاع ايضا
واكد ايضا مراسله العربيه الان انه لم يتم
حتى الان تفعيل صفارات الانذار في المناطق
الاسرائيليه اذا الان هناك ايضا كان انباء
متداوله حول السقوط صاروخ في منطقه غير
ماهوله في محيط او في غلاف غزه هل
بالتاكيدات حول هذه المعلومه لنا
يعني حتى الان لا يوجد لدينا معلومات
موثوقه حول هذا الموضوع ولكن يعني
التوترات الموجوده في قطاع غزه هي موجوده
منذ الاسابيع الاخيره وتخوفات ايضا من
تفجر الاوضاع وتدخل قطاع غزه ايضا
بالتوترات الموجوده في الضفه الغربيه نظرا
لاننا نقترب كثيرا من شهر رمضان المتوقع
ايضا ان يكون هناك انفجار كبير في القدس
الشرقيه وايضا في الضفه الغربيه بسبب ايضا
استمرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه
باستمرارها
القوانين ايضا يعني شاهدنا ايضا ليله امس
كان هناك مصادقه على بالقراءه الثانيه
والثالثه ايضا بقانون وهو يعني الغاء بعض
بنود من انفصال اسرائيل من انفصال اسرائيل
احادي الجانب عن قطاع غزه وايضا الضفه
الغربيه ما يعني يؤدي الى ارجاع
المستوطنين الذين تم اخلائهم عام 2005 من
اربع مستوطنات قريبين من جنين ونابلس حيث
هناك يعني دائما تكون المشاكل والتوترات